hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und zwar war ich jetzt
eine woche auf stufen fahrt in venedig
jesolo italien blase überall so bisschen
von warte ich schon mal ganz kurz hier
in meinem kalender von samstag dem 13
eine freitag freitag den 12 bis heute
samstag den zwanzigsten also acht tage
ca und ich hab bei facebook gepostet und
unter die youtube-videos geschrieben
dass ich jetzt im urlaub bin deswegen
keine videos kommen ich hab sogar den
videos gesagt und ich komme wieder und
ich gucke mir meine videos an und die
sehe
hey leute ich muss euch echt sagen lukas
gestorben deswegen kommen keine videos
gibt's den daumen hoch
17 daumen hoch warum solltet ihr so was
ab ich hab mir facebook bilder gepostet
anderer kommentar
lp hey leute ihr werdet es mir nicht
glauben aber das ist kein scheiß aber
luca hatte ein auto und weil er es nicht
holen aber sehr schwer verletzte muss
jetzt im rollstuhl bleiben kein scheiß
trauriger smiley nach videos warum keine
videos zum letzten mal der a2 stand
heute zum letzten mal da kommen kräfte
längere zeit in italien das kommt erst
am 21
wieder videos schaut es auf facebook
nach so er hat als einziger der hat drei
daumen hoch warum hat er nur drei daumen
hoch
aber dieser komische andere fuzzy der
behauptet dass ich irgendwie tot bin
oder einen autounfall hatte wird wie
kommt man darauf verzichten autounfall
hat wahrlich an ihm autobahn
meine fresse ich bin ich bin 17 solche
leute den kommt man echt stelle links
schnelle rechtshänder niveau vergraben
oder irgendwie so hat es das ist die
größte scheiße dies gibt auf dieser welt
wenn man sagt wenn man und wenn man von
leuten was behauptet was nicht stimmt es
ja schon schlimm
und wenn das irgendwie mit tod oder
eigentlichen unfällen zusammenhängen
dass ich deswegen deine videos mache das
ist einfach nur noch unmenschlich wenn
diese personen die würde ich tausend mal
blocken und stelle links schnelle rechts
und alles ist schrecklich so was ich
hasse sowas also stellt mir keine
anforderungen lasst mich einfach jetzt
gerade neue kommentare kommen auch sein
geld einfach kommentar conny ich kriege
auch immer wieder mails täglich kong
kräftig hab da mal ne frage das war
nichts mehr schön blog ich habe gesagt
schreibt mails wenn es wichtig ist und
nicht verändert dann einfach mir
schreibt er ich hab ne frage blablabla
also war das regt mich auf so was ich
war in venedig ob stufen fahrt sieben
tage und ich werde auch bald noch mal
weg sein und zwar vom 28 07 bis zum 15
achten weil mir meine freizeit und
freunde und urlaub irgendwie wichtiger
ist als youtube das ist einfach so
youtube ist für mich ein hobby genauso
wie ich gerne in urlaub fahre das ist
für mich auch ein hobby oder gerne was
mit freunden mache und die hobby stehen
für mich über youtube ihr müsst euch
jetzt nicht beleidigt fühlen aber wenn
man wiederkommt und anstatt dass man
liest hey luca wann kommt nochmal neue
videos oder halo k viel spaß in italien
schön ist bisher wieder da macht er
heute ein video liest man halo kan ist
einem autounfall gestorben pay luca hat
sich darunter verletzt hey luca ist tot
17 leuten 17 leute leiten das
beziehungsweise wollten das hoch weil es
angeblich stimmt gegen die stirn alter
[ __ ] hat dann sonnenbrand ferner ist das
nicht so klug und jetzt an wehzutun nein
also ich lebe noch und lp du bist ein
verdammt das ist echt scheiße vor allem
die ganzen anderen die ausgeschriebenen
[ __ ] euch einfach [ __ ] euch von mir
aus schreibt jetzt in kommentare halo
kids siehst du deine abonnenten solche
leute brauche ich nicht die nenne ich
auch nicht abonnenten das einfach nur
verdammt lieb
das ist verdammt gut wo ich jetzt grade
schon so dabei bin hier so ein bisschen
einfach zu quatschen
steffen stellte stefan block der andere
typ hier mit videos machen
der kauft sich gold auf minecraft david
eine serie kommen die steffen lernt
minecraft heißt oder kontrast bringt
stefan kreft
da zeige ich bringe ich immer meine
kraft war das wird extrem witzig glaube
ich ja das wird bald kommen und mega
projekt wird heute auch noch eine folge
kommen ich bin mal wiedergekommen ist 11
und für mich kommt gerade vor 7 uhr
abend bei wir sind 18 stunden warten
ja ja das war meine mutter also wie lok
echt immer so provisorisch einfach so
drauflos gequatsche ich werde das auch
nicht vorstellen damit dass jetzt
einfach mal so ganz
kolibris und hier alles mitkriegt
mega projekt wird heute noch kommen dann
werde ich auch noch ein paar andere
sachen auf die man bei ich bin heute
abend noch mal auf so eine beach party
und morgen auch noch mal feiern deswegen
wird wahrscheinlich erst wieder videos
ab dem 22
nicht ab dem 21 und ja also fragt euch
nicht warum manche youtuber keine
motivation für youtube haben bzw
aufhören so wie ich das hätte einige
zeit lang in betracht gezogen hat weil
für solche spastik hab ich kein bock
videos zu machen also ich will ich
spreche jetzt wieder nicht alle an
sondern nur die einigen nicht dass jetzt
wenn ich nur einen kommentar lesen
luca wgs mit deinen abonnenten um
schreibt lieber luca weg wie gehen die
abonnenten mit luca umschreibt das
lieber weil ich bin nur ein mensch ich
bin 17 jahre alt ich gehe noch zur
schule ich bin auf stufen fahrt und es
wird spekuliert dass ich tot bin
mit dem erzielten spekuliert es wird
einfach geschrieben dass ich tot bin
jetzt ist es ist laut jp und auch
anderen leuten einfach so passiert dass
ich ein autounfall hatte angeblich ja
sehr schön wenn wir dann nach hause
kommt sowas dann erfährt er gut wenn ich
bock blatt noch mega projekt offen ich
schließlich meine kanal mache ich nicht
aber dann würde ich erst mal sagen euch
noch einen schönen tag und ich bin nicht
ich lebe noch und mega projekt kommt
heute und mein gott es nicht einfach an
solche leute jetzt einfach nur